[Applause]
hi everybody I'm Jessica Chobot and
we're here at the Daytona International
Speedway the world center of racing with
Indy racecar driver Ryan hunter-reay
we're taking Ryan off the track and
putting him behind the wheels of Forza
Motorsport 5 on Microsoft's Xbox one
does one of America's most successful
drivers have what it takes to go up
against our pro gamer on the Virtual
track there's only one way to find out
GameSpot presents player vs. gamer meet
our player Ryan hunter-reay is a 2012
IZOD IndyCar champion for Andretti
Autosport has captured nine career
victories in IndyCar competition holds
the record 250 for most laps led in a
single IndyCar race and when he's not
racing cars Ryan enjoys scuba diving
surfing and sports and fishing before we
get Ryan behind the wheels and force of
five I wanted to talk to him about the
games he used to play as a kid so I know
you're getting prepped to test the car
it's quite a bit noisy here in your
garage but can I just talk to you for a
few a couple seconds to get to know
absolutely we have a couple minutes
before we're heading out for practice so
we've got you into racing in the first
place like what how old were you and
thought about it sparked your interest I
had always just been about going fast
taking risks you know whether it be on a
bike or anything else and my dad made
the mistake of buying me a little
go-kart for the neighborhood I got in a
lot of trouble in that and that got me
onto a racetrack and then I got into the
Skip Barber Racing School and and it's
just a ladder system from there so I
feel like I have the best job in the
world you know get paid to do what I
love and I get to drive cars like like
this Viper
and the Indy car and I've got to pinch
myself sometimes but it's always new
challenges in this sport so I really
love it now you know racing is a very
outdoor outside sport you know a lot of
Nintendo back in the day of course I
mean everybody has right Tecmo Bowl
super technical and a lot of Mario Kart
and then and then what's the real gaming
got going you know with with Xbox 360
you can start to use it to learn tracks
and that's the unique thing and that's
that's a future of where our sport is
going when you can really get a lot of
track time and a lot of experience in
before you get in the actual race car do
you feel like having having played some
of those games when you get to the track
of yourself are you ever surprised or
impressed that they're very accurate or
do you notice inconsistencies and does
that kind of throw you off yeah
sometimes you notice that
inconsistencies but you know with an
accurate game like we have on xbox one
four to five it's I mean the track
models are pristine
yeah the cars may handle just a touch
different in some ways that when I'm
used to from I'm holding a steering
wheel but the tracks are spot on the
cars detail spot on and and the vehicle
dynamics the cars actual you know
characteristics are right on the money
okay so we got a glimpse of how it works
in Ryan's world this is how it's gonna
go down in ours we've got the Xbox one
setup and the title for today Forza
Motorsport 5 4 is the 5 is a cinematic
automotive journey
it features unmatched visual realism
hundreds of cars that are perfectly
recreated and is built from the ground
up to take advantage of the new
generation it is the definitive racing
game only possible on Xbox one
for more on Forza 5 here's GameSpot
editor Chris water hey Jessica
before I get started I have a confession
to make I'm just not that into cars but
every so often a racing game comes along
that makes me think okay I can see how I
would get really into this Ward's of
motorsport five is one of those games
for starters this is one of the few
next-gen games that actually looks
next-gen the visual realism on display
is stunning with hundreds of cars
rendered in loving detail from classic
sports cars and modern imports to open
wheel race cars and extreme exotics if
the broadest assortment of vehicles this
venerable racing series has ever seen
and it's not just the cars that look
great the gorgeous tracks practically
begged to be raced upon from the soaring
peaks of the Bernese Alps to the
beautiful architecture of Prague tortas
technical prowess extends under the hood
as well each car is tuned to feel just
right and the impulse triggers of the
Xbox one's controller offer tactile
feedback that gives you an extra degree
of sensitivity and control it all adds
up to an incredible racing experience
one that will thrill car enthusiasts and
entice even the most reluctant racers to
take a turn behind the wheel it's the
best game on the Xbox one and it's only
on the Xbox one
Jessica you guys are gonna have a blast
with this one happy racing
I'm back here with Ryan hunter-reay so
what are you doing here at the
International Speedway today well we're
here testing the SRT Viper GTS R for the
Daytona 24 hours coming up in two weeks
so we come here for three or four days
we run through all the different
schematics of setup and everything that
we need to do to get ready for a 24 hour
race which you can imagine is pretty
it's pretty grueling so it's hard on the
equipment it's hard on the drivers one
of the best races in the world though
and it's just awesome to be here to be a
part of it how do you do that to win
days it's strictly bragging rights oh do
you actually walk away with well it's
part of a series a championship but when
you win it you get a Rolex Daytona and
yeah when you win a Rolex Daytona at the
24 Hours of Daytona it's probably the
the most priceless watch you can have
out there yeah so I really want to watch
first car I ever owned you know I wanted
a good deal you go fast and it was a
Camaro I didn't have a mullet or
anything like that can't go wrong there
so the two cars that you have in courts
of five how accurate are they to you
when you play them I mean it's pretty
cool there's two parts that I actually
currently drive in in Forza 5 on the
xbox one and I think they're very
accurate I mean you really have to you
you have to pay respect to the car you
can't just step on the brakes and get
back on the gas you have to really worry
about weight management where that where
the transfer of weight is going in the
corner so all that stuff it says a lot
that you can't just get in it and go
fast but you wouldn't be able to do if
you jumped right in this so it's the
same thing on the video again you really
have to learn it you have to you have to
adapt to it and I think it's becoming
closer to a simulator than a video game
do you find that you're bringing your
video game to the actual racing game
like when you're and by that I mean
you're in your car you're racing do you
kind of go boom boom to yourself you're
like not quite that way but but similar
in a way that if I hadn't been to a
track before I will pull up the video
game in the console and try and get and
try and get to on that track before I go
there just to familiarize yourself you
know before you get out there and in a
real race car my side
two personal cars in the game are there
any other cars that you see in the game
that you're kind of like whoo okay
absolutely
the Niki Lauda's f1 car that's the one
that I really want to get in some
Ferrari and I can't wait to get my hands
on that it's my favorite era of racing
knowing that everyone's car has been
scanned and it accurately reproduced for
the game would it be considered cheating
to like drive somebody else's car on a
virtual track in preparation for an
actual race come on if it's available to
you you got to use it
it's a tool it's a five-hour race later
on what come are you going to go with
today I've got to go with both my cars
I've got to go with the Indy car and the
Viper we'll start out with hopefully
with the Indy car and then go to the
Viper nice well are you ready to meet
your opponent I'm ready to meet my
opponent all right let's go stay tuned
for more player versus gamer after this
break
all right so now it's time to meet our
pro gamer Michael LaBelle hello Michael
thanks for joining us how's it going
good so how did you get into programming
well I started back in 2005 actually and
I was just playing a lot of FIFA online
and I realized that I've had a
competitive advantage and I started
going to tournaments and I was able to
win win some national titles next door
have you gotten any hands-on time with
forts of five yet I have not played the
game yet I picked it up and I just
didn't get a chance to put it in so
you're driving blind I&E shall we say
sure so have you had a chance with Xbox
one what do you think of that
I love the Xbox one I think that it's a
dominant console looks beautiful and
definitely next-gen are you nervous at
all knowing that you haven't had
experience with 4 to 5 yet to go up
against a pro driver we're gonna put
Ryan to the test we're gonna see what
that was what's happening with Ryan this
might be out of his uh his realm unless
he plays a lot of simulation and then I
might be in for some big trouble
not a lot of simulation though just
getting the real thing
the real driving which is awesome that's
why I just just letting you know
yeah I saw that he wants some some major
things in his career I did some research
I was seeing I could bring up in good
points very cool
all right well being that you guys are
both pro in your respective fields do
you think you're pretty evenly matched I
think so you know I'm stepping into his
arena with the with with the gaming you
know side of it and then he's coming in
to mind you know with vehicle dynamics
and working on the tracks and you know I
know some of these tracks and so that'll
be different for him so it's pretty
evenly matched I'd say I'd say there's
quite right because I'm good at gaming
but don't have any racing experience
he's great at racing doesn't have that
much gaming experience this is gonna go
down we're gonna do best two out of
three if you happen to tie the third
race is going to be a drag race drag a
drag race spoiler alert for those of you
at home up to this point all of our
episodes only the pro gamer has one so
Ryan we are really really got our eyes
peeled on you
I'm ready don't f it up man all right on
your mark get set go
[Music]
so I'm pretty psyched about this this is
my my actual number one DHL IndyCar it
looks great the teaser when I saw it
it's pretty much what my dreams are made
of so I was pretty I'm pretty psyched to
take the first couple laps here so I'm
gonna beat you in your car that's not
gonna okay I just wanna okay magical sea
ring the graphics are unreal I mean all
this stuff is even the signs or the
exact one is is on fire
definitely top notch oh boy maybe a good
start
No
this could be alcohol that's how you
race huh Wow I'm not sure if I want to
get involved in this first turn
what really Wow accidents hit me right
from behind huh we're going for wins
[Applause]
oh wow
oh no the bump of alright I did a little
off-road for you oh my goodness
Carla's straight though huh in the lawn
even we got out of the grass oh good
I'm out of the grass alright good
laundry
[Music]
and we're back in the grass I'm trying
to think these turns tighter and it's
not going for me
oh I can see you in the radar okay
move that oh no that was a we had a
pretty heated first laptop
it's very sensitive which I guess yeah
that's my wife yeah that's good yeah I'm
just blown away by the graphics I'm
eating the marks on the pavement are
exactly around
this is bad another breath I can't smile
back straight right here no I think
you're good to go I think this one's
been oh this is when you start smiling
in the helmet right here this is like
chugging the milk and stuff happening
yeah well that would be after this
Victor is here nice I get to keep my car
yeah well good game good game and good
race
you took the brakes number one we got
race number two and I think this car is
gonna go to my advantage you've had a
lot of comfort role in the Indy deal
I've got some experience in vipers I'm
just saying do you a little bit a little
bit a little razzle-dazzle I'm lucky
because I you actually both the cars
that are in this game you know I get to
drive in real life so I've got that edge
on you but I don't know I took that
first one pretty pretty convincingly but
yeah I got it you maybe the balance will
go my way this time around pick the next
track let's do it okay are you ready for
a match number two now you ready for a
bite out of a wardrobe change mr.
Hollywood mr. Hollywood
yeah my car alright so I've got to
change my and we want to try different
track it's up to you yeah that one
didn't go so well for me so uh unless
they were hiring me for long duty we're
gonna have to change up some things or
sort of hey you know a grass do you have
a preference road Atlanta's a fun one
okay Road Atlanta it is ready round two
I'm ready to go outrageous are we just
going straight up no it's straight into
it alright now there's also beautiful
grass
I already know what's about to happen
here I know what you're about I know I
know whether that what happens in these
races whoa buddy look at that hit and
run I'm trying to hit and run
smashing dad here comes the long guy oh
boy this is just such a different track
here oh boy
Oh dog guy that comes along guy know
what your dirty dirty my Kevin oh I see
what you're doing back there you're
waiting on the turn come smack yeah I
knew I knew I know say I tried to play
dirty
yeah come on buddy come on buddy driver
handle this one now oh you're still in
the radar who's anything happening
besides I'm known as the grass man I
hope they've been done I see it see it
coming
No
oh my goodness oh come on this should be
interesting
this time they might get come back I
feel like you're gonna screw up I want
to let you know right now do it I feel
your screw up know what the turf thing
crap oh yeah I don't think it matters
I won't mind oversee won't mind bear
that over eyes I stay in the grass
that's done good game my friend good
game man um you guys have seen this at
home I owe you guys apology I'll let you
down
you know what I would have felt like
though if you would have beat me in my
own car and both of them you learned a
few things though the winner of two out
of a possible three races and the first
time ever we had an athlete win at one
of these events everybody big round of
applause for Ryan
I'm so sorry but I look forward to your
career in log management thankfully I'm
majoring in horticulture I'm working on
cutting down weeds and and we're doing
our thing but congratulations on your
new future guys will our athlete win in
the next round the only way to find out
is to tune in to more episodes of player
vs. gamer
[Music]
[Music]